hey youtubers is Charlie so the internet
blew up this morning they announced that
Hawkgirl and rip hunter are coming to
the arrow flash spinoff they haven't
confirmed what the title is going to be
but I'm just gonna call a spade a spade
and say it's Justice Society braving the
bold would be like the second likely
option they had a team up braving the
bull cartoon and a lot of these
characters that they're casting have
appeared in The Brave and the bold
comics over the years in my head though
just as society just sounds like it has
better name recognition and they would
want to lead with that if they could but
it's possible that DC comics won't let
them use Justice Society in that case I
think braving the bullet would be to go
to they haven't finished casting yet
there's still a few characters that I
think that they're trying to lock down
and they haven't announced who the main
villain is going to be even though they
do have two villains already they have
Captain cold and heat wave but I don't
think they'll be the main villains
they're more like neutral characters so
they'll do evil things but they'll also
help the heroes if it suits them so just
to do a roundup here is a breakdown of
the cast that they have so far starting
with the heroes there's the Ray Palmer
atom he's probably gonna bankroll the
team running a superhero team is is
super expensive so having a billionaire
around comes in handy it's just like
Batman bankrolling the outsiders team
then we have caity lotz in an unknown
role I have some theories about that
that I'll explain in a sec most of them
involve her being a totally different
character like she's not gonna be a
resurrected Sara Lance then we have
Martin Stein and since Robbie Amell is
not listed on the cast don't assume that
it's gonna be firestorm on the show
it'll just be normal Martin Stein most
of the time he'll be like a scientist on
the team and then obviously we have
Hawkgirl and rip hunter
Hawkgirl is going to be played by Sierra
Renee you probably never heard of her
before she's mostly done Broadway shows
rip hunter of course Arthur Darvill from
Doctor Who just adding to the giant list
of Doctor Who characters that have
transitioned to the arrow flash universe
Andrew Kreisberg
is a giant Doctor Who fan so you have
him to thank for casting all these
Doctor Who characters rip hunter is a
time-traveling character they've already
established that time travel is the
thing in this universe on the flash TV
show so I think a lot of the people that
they're casting will give you an idea
for what they will and will not be doing
on the show most of the powers and
everything is is science-based it can be
explained by science but Marc Guggenheim
said that because of the VIX
Digital cartoon series they're doing
magic will be a part of the universe -
that's gonna be in continuity with these
other shows it's just vixen won't be a
live-action character I'll explain how
the vixen stuff is connected later
because they haven't aired any footage
yet but they have been working on
episodes so moving over into like the
the villain category we have captain
cold and heatwave
like I said they're not gonna be like
the big bad what I think is gonna happen
is is because this is a superhero
team-up show they will build towards a
super villain team eventually but there
will be like a single big bad they'll be
like a Merlin rachel gould type
character who will lead a team of his
own like an evil team we're talking
crime syndicate injustice society some
version of something like that that
being said i think it's gonna take them
a while to build up to that so we'll
meet like the main villain and then
eventually they'll build up towards like
a super villain team but maybe not -
like season two and just to be clear the
show has not been picked up for like a
full series yet they're getting ready to
fill in a pilot after that's done the CW
will probably make a decision as to
whether or not it'll pick it up and then
they'll start rolling into production
for actual episodes for now though the
commitment is pretty strong i think
unless something goes really really
wrong when they filmed the pilot unless
something goes terribly wrong i think
it's all but guaranteed to be picked up
for series greg berlanti said that they
did know which character would be the
main villain they just haven't cast him
yet Berlanti said that he is like one of
the biggest DC characters one of the
biggest DC villains that has not been
seen on-screen yet that hasn't been used
in a big way so I think he's talking
about Vandal Savage he showed up in the
animated shows but I don't think he was
talking about the animated shows when he
said on screen typically everyone views
the live-action in the cartoon stuff is
completely separate so right now the
biggest Justice Society villain that
they haven't seen on-screen in a big way
is Vandal Savage the other really good
option for the villain especially if
they're gonna do the Brave and the bold
if that's gonna be the name of the
series would be Libra that was a big
Justice League villain I know he does
some weird stuff like there's some weird
twists to the character during Final
Crisis especially with the flash family
just ignore that and remember that Libra
was able to steal all the powers of the
Justice League and he went around
putting a team of supervillains together
it would definitely play into the idea
of ESCA
superheroes team-up villains team up in
response really though I'd rather see
them call the show Justice Society and
go with Vandal Savage but either one are
really big possibilities Libra is just a
little more mysterious and and gives
them a backdoor to tie things back into
the flash TV show I don't want to give
away like major Final Crisis spoilers
especially if they haven't announced the
villain yet once once they do I'll do
more videos for the villains
specifically I know there are a lot of
other big super villains but you have to
remember that certain people are off
limits because of characters that the
movies are doing so Vandal Savage is
probably someone who will not show up in
the DC movies so that's why I think this
TV show can use them
I'm also excluding a lot of magic based
characters because of Constantine if
Constantine gets canceled I think that
they'll open the doors towards like dr.
fate more magical stuff in the
arrowverse none of that's confirmed
though yes there is magic in the arrow
universe but there probably a ton of
characters that they can't use for now
that is just for now things always
change just in terms of rolling stuff
out for this spin-off show like
confirming stuff I think what they'll do
is they'll confirm the title and they'll
show like a logo and a picture of the
cast in costume before the arrow and
flash finales this year that still a
ways off I don't know that they'll have
a trailer ready in time for that but
they might show a promo when we get to
comic-con later this summer
they'll probably air the pilot if they
have it ready it depends on when they
finish filming usually they can turn
pilots over pretty fast May is usually
the time when most networks decide on
pilots so that's usually when most
pilots finished shooting which is more
than enough time to get it ready to show
at Comic Con what I think would happen
is is if everything goes according to
plan the show gets picked up it'll just
air at the same time air on the flash
does just on a different night it'll be
like a Monday night show or Thursday
night the real question now is is who is
caity lotz playing on the show option 8
she's Sarah Lance resurrected in the
Lazarus Pit option B is that she's a
completely different character and has
nothing to do with Sarah Lance right now
the most common theory is is that she's
going to be someone completely different
she's not gonna have anything to do with
Sarah Lance
Caity Lotz will just have like a
slightly different look and they might
make some jokes about it whenever arrow
crosses over with them none of that's
been confirmed but I do think that they
will explain what's going on before the
arrow flash finales this year so you
want it to wait too long to find out so
here are the people
I think she could be playing just going
from least likely to most likely I will
start with Cassandra Cain that the bat
girl I don't know that they're gonna let
them straight up use a Batman character
in a bat costume that just feels very
unlikely
then there's Miss Martian it would it
would certainly explain why she looks
like Sarah Lance she could look like
however she wanted to look like she'd
also have some pretty badass powers
remember we have Hawkgirl who is the
most mystical powerful person on the
team as far as we know there's lady
Metamorpho or element girl however you
want to think about her she has special
powers like metahuman abilities she was
also inducted into the Justice League at
the same time as firestorm and the
female atom slightly more likely but
just depends on whether or not they want
to give her special powers then there's
Liberty Bell or Jessie quick that would
involve getting into speed based powers
so it'll be more of like a flash
crossover I think most speedsters if we
do see Jessie quick will be introduced
on the flash though I think they'll keep
it on that show and my number one pick
if she's gonna be like a totally
different character if she's not gonna
be like a resurrected Sara Lance I think
she's gonna be star girl that's a
character that was created by Geoff
Johns in the comics when he first came
to DC the character herself is a real
love letter to his sister who died in a
plane crash
he gave the character his sister's name
Courtney so it was a big love letter to
her so them casting her on the show
would be a big love letter to that too
it'd just be a very poignant thing we go
from late 90s Geoff Johns first joining
DC Comics as a writer to present-day
where he is like the creative director
for all of DC Comics working on a TV
version of the comic book that he used
to write I just I feel like that fits
star girl does have the cosmic rod that
she uses to fly which which is a little
weird based on the powers that we've
seen on the show so far so they might
change that but she is a really awesome
mechanic which I think would make her
fit in with Ray Palmer's character
really well just in general it seems
like the team they're putting together
is gonna be more science-based like most
of their powers will evolve from a
science with a little bit of magic a la
Hawkgirl and vixen here might be
questions for you guys
who do you want caity lotz to be on this
spinoff show and who do you want the big
villain to be there are a lot of
questions as to like who they're gonna
bring in as show runners like how much
of that they're gonna take on themselves
with their existing team right now Marc
Guggenheim is showrunner on air
I mean he's always been showrunner on
arrow Andrew Kreisberg is showrunner on
the flash but he's also going to be
writing just writing for Supergirl
they haven't named a showrunner for that
and then they're gonna need a new
showrunner for this other spin-off show
you have to remember that even those
like Supergirl is at CBS it's still a
Berlanti show so you still have a lot of
arrow flash people collaborating on
stuff I know it gets a little confusing
when you talk about like the production
people behind the scenes because it's
like the same group of people making
these shows but some of them are at a
different network so they're technically
not as connected as the ones that same
networks so I'll try to explain as we go
along and don't worry I'm totally gonna
do weekly videos for Justice Society or
All Starz or whatever they end up
calling the show that's why I think that
first episode is gonna be them forming
the team and everyone will have their
superpowers so we're not gonna have to
wait for Hawkgirl to become Hawkgirl in
that first episode she'll already be
that character the next step for the
arrow universe though is magic like they
have to introduce magic in a convincing
way we've had time-travel like that's a
pretty crazy concept so now magic is the
next step I know a lot of you guys are
asking for like Justice Society Justice
League videos stuff like that I'm gonna
wait till they officially confirm what
the show's name is going to be before
digging like really deep into the comics
so most of my bonus videos for this will
just focus on the specific characters
they've announced so but I'll probably
do for my next bonus video for the
spin-off show is do like a Hawkgirl
video just do like my favorite Hawkgirl
stories from the comics be sure to
subscribe to get that I've also got a
couple other videos I'm gonna try and
post before the flash at least by
Wednesday morning I my Walking Dead Q&A
and I have a special crunchyroll
giveaway I know everyone always likes
bonus giveaways well you guys wait for
that stuff to drop you can click here
for my latest flash video and click here
to learn all about some new stuff from
the Deadpool movie they just confirmed
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you